voici ce qu'il resterait de cet élevage
de volaille située à carpati dans la
région de luansk en Ukraine envahit par
les Russes un toit criblé d'impact le
site a été bombardé et il y aurait
plusieurs victimes selon Moscou en
Russie cette fois c'est la raffinerie
d'afibski qui a été visé dans la nuit
ces dernières heures les attaques en
territoire russe se multiplient la
raffinerie d'afibski mais aussi celle
d'illski dans cette même région ont été
touchées plus au nord c'est la ville de
chez béquino dans la région de Belgorod
qui a été prise pour cible
cette nuit ou plutôt ce matin vers 3h15
il y a une attaque de missiles massive
sur chez vekino beaucoup de destruction
des immeubles des maisons des voitures
ont brûlées quatre personnes ont été
blessées elles sont en train d'être
soignées dieu merci personne n'est mort
dans cette même région frontalière de
l'Ukraine les autorités ont même annoncé
évacué des enfants face aux
bombardements de plus en plus fréquents
ce mardi c'était la capitale russe
Moscou qui était visée par des attaques
de drones sur des bâtiments d'habitation
une provocation selon le Kremlin qui
assure avoir la main sur la situation
nous sommes inquiets de cette situation
les bombardements des infrastructures
civiles continuent et nous n'avons
entendu aucune condamnation de la part
des pays occidentaux
de son côté l'Ukraine n'a pas
officiellement revendiqué ses frappes
tieve fait l'objet d'attaquer intense et
massif de missiles et de drones ces
derniers jours les autorités affirment
que la capitale a subi sa plus
importante attaque de drone depuis le
début de la guerre cette semaine